the world is a vast and often
unmanageable place so no wonder if we
sometimes display a powerful attraction
to the idea of miniaturization we seem
to love dolls houses teddies train sets
bonsai trees model aeroplanes and tiny
cups and sources sitting on the sides of
miniaturized kitchens these all please
us by symbolizing a taming and
humanizing of the gigantic dimensions of
much of life by far the easiest and
fastest way to miniaturize the world is
not by making models of it but through
the use of what linguists call
diminutives a diminutive is a word
that's been modified to suggest a
smaller version of itself usually
through a tweak to its ending
interestingly the moment when we're
tempted to use a diminutive is often the
moment we start to love someone or
something the more we feel drawn the
more we want to possess them to tame
their other nests an intimidating scale
and therefore to shrink them down to
something more manageable something that
might almost slip into our pocket when a
couple let's call them EMA and Brad get
together they might swiftly add some
diminutive x' to their burgeoning
relationship
Brad's vagabond Footloose sides can be
tamed by a little why so that he becomes
Brad E and Emma might shrink by being
called M e it's particularly interesting
to find that not all languages use
diminutives to the same extent the
champion is Spanish especially as spoken
in Latin America Latin Americans are
constantly trying to shrink everything
in Mexico ahora
in a minute becomes a harita in just a
little second un poco a little gets
changed to un paquete in just a smidgen
a coffee un cafe is constantly changed
into uncaf Eden or un cafe Lito that
doesn't make you coffee any smaller but
it does bring you into a more intimate
kind of relationship to it Italian is
another language very keen on
diminutives usually with the addition of
an
II know inna an old man in Italian when
Vecchio becomes Vecchio a little boy
died God saw becomes that I get see know
a woman Donna becomes donnetta
a car Makena becomes maki Netta german
often seen it's a formal harsh language
also has a flair for diminutives the
suffixes shin and line can be added to
many words a sausage I'm washed can be
turned into inversion which isn't
necessarily a smaller sausage but it is
one that is particularly irresistible
likewise ein union isn't necessarily a
smaller dog than in hunt but it's
probably a dog that you have a soft spot
for the major language notable for a
lack of diminutives
is english at best in english we can add
an e or a dirt very poor moves compared
to the great richness of diminutives in
other languages we might wonder why this
is perhaps English the global language
the language of conquest and empire
resists the accommodation with the
modest the everyday and the tender which
other languages pave the way for we may
lack diminutives because it's that
little bit harder to be tender in
english or more importantly as an
english person
diminutives do the valuable job of
rehabilitating sweetness they remind us
that we have come from childhood and
that when we love we want to shrink the
world back down to a more manageable and
lovable scale we know that we are the
objects of someone's affection when they
start to shrink us down and we shouldn't
hesitate to shrink down the bits of the
world that we have begun to care for
this has been a message from what the
Germans might term the school of life
line or the Italians might call the
school of life Etta thank you for
watching liking and subscribing if you
want more why not visit us in person and
attend a class or take a look at our
shop at the link on your screen now
you